Hi I'm Brett Slatkin, a
software engineer on the
Google App Engine team.
App Engine enables editors to
build web applications on
Google's infrastructure.
I'm here today to show you how
to quickly build a guest book
application using App Engine.
Let's get started.
First we'll create a directory
for my new application and
bring it into my editor.
Then I'll create an "app.yamo"
file with my
application configuration.
I'll type my application name.
Version of this application,
in this case
the first version.
Version of the apis I'm going
to be using.
And the runtime,
which is "python."
Then I declare how my URL is
going to map
to my application.
In this case, I'm going to
have all URLs go to single
python scripts called "main."
I'll create my
main python file.
I'll type in a very basic,
"Hello world" application.
Now I'll go to the terminal
and start the
development web server.
And now that the server is
running, I can go and view the
"Hello World" application.
Now let's do something more
complicated and build
a web application.
To do this we've provided a
very basic web application
framework called "Web App."
I'll import the "Web App"
module and then define a
handler, which will handle
the requests from
the application.
The methods of this class
will handle HTP requests.
In this case, I just want to
handle a get request, and I'll
print out a
"Hello World" message.
Text "schema handler
" I'll use "wsgiref," which is
python standard
web application container.
And I'll define a
"WSGIApplication" throughout
all URL's access to my
really basic handler.
And of course, tell phython
to run my main function.
Now let's view this
in our browser.
Great. It showed up
and it's working.
Now let's do some templates to
make this page look better.
We provide a basic
library for doing this.
Let's create a template file
using Django templates.
To begin with, I'll just have
some HTML that says,
"Hello World."
I'll import our
template module.
And then render the template.
And then I can view
this in my browser.
Now let's implement a basic
UI for our web application.
I'll go back into my template
file and start writing my
UI and HTML.
So first I'll have a form.
In this case, I want to post.
And the form will have
a couple of fields.
Since it's a guest book, let's
start off with the message
I want to have.
In this case, it's just text
fields with "message."
And we'll change the "submit"
button to say "shout."
And now we can go back
and view this in our browser.
So let's have our web
application handle the post
request and then do
something more interesting.
I'll modify "MyHandler" to
handle post requests, as well
as the "get" requests.
Now let's hook this
up to the data store.
To use the data store, I'll
import the dv module and to
find a model class that says
what fields will have to store
in the data store.
In this case, my model class
will be called "Shout."
And I'll have two fields.
First, the message.
And then the time the
message was left.
Now, in the post method, I'll
use the request parameters to
create a new "Shout" and
put it in the data store.
Then I'll redirect the user
back to the main page.
Then I can go back to my
browser and see this is
working right now.
Now we're handling posts and
putting posts and putting data
in the data store,
but we're no retrieving it.
So let's create a query to get
the data back out and
present it to the user.
To do this I'll
create a "GqlQuery."
And then I'll use the results
of the query to
populate my templates.
And passes values
into the template renderer.
Then if I go into my template,
I can use the results of the
query and render them
to the user.
In this case,
I'm using Django templates.
Now I can go back to my
browser and see this is
immediately working.
And there are my two
requests from before.
Now I can type of few
more messages.
You'll see they are not in
any particular order.
So I'd like to add a sort
order to my query.
New messages go to the top.
I'll modify my model to have
another property,
which is
"who set the message?"
In this case, it's optional
because some of the messages
were sent without
an explicit sender.
Then I'm going to go to my
template and add
that new field.
It would also be good to have
labels on these input fields.
Then I need to make sure that
when I create my shot I've
correctly populated
the "who" field.
I'd also like to render who
sent each message.
So, I'll go back to my
template and add that too.
In the case the "who" field is
empty, I'll just say
it's from anonymous.
Now let's go back to the
browser and see what
this looks like.
You can see all the messages
are from anonymous because
none of them has a sender.
Let's add a new one
with a sender for me.
You'll see my name
has appeared.
One last thing I'm going to do
is fix the title to point out
this is my application
called "shoutout!"
For this application,
I'll use the App Config Tool.
I'll just type, "appcfig
update" to deploy my
application and then the
naming application directory.
And we're done.
Now I can access this
application on appspot.com.
Now let's leave a message.
That's it. We built an
application and deployed it.
We hope that you check
out Google App Engine.
We look forward to
hearing your comments.
If you'd like to learn more
about App Engine, please join
us at Google IO, Google's
developer event on
May 28th and 29th.
Thanks for watching.